le sous-officier Shane Janney dit pouvez-vous le
dire mr.  Patton, s'il te plaît, a fait le tour du
monde deux fois,
parle à tout le monde une fois qu'il n'y a
rien, je ne peux pas faire de tombe céleste, je sais que tu
vois trop dur,
je suis un amoureux, je suis un combattant, je suis un plongeur UDT Navy
SEAL, écoute, euh  Les Red Wings, un
méchant commandant supérieur des talibans, ont tué
20 Marines la semaine dernière 20 avec une équipe de
quatre hommes TP, il y a beaucoup plus de
10 gars, c'est une armée, ce bureau est
compromis, je le vois, nous avons deux
options, l'une laisse-le partir  est-ce que la
seconde où ils courent là-bas, nous en avons
200 sur le dos - nous résilions le
compromis, nous ne pouvons pas faire ça Je ne
pense pas que ce ne soit pas un vote, nous allons
les lâcher et nous rentrons à la maison d'
accord  ce monsieur
dit-il parfaitement dans un joli coup de feu
il y a une tempête à l'intérieur de nous mon dieu
conduit
et poussez-vous plus loin que quiconque
ne pourrait penser possible vous pouvez mourir pour
votre pays je vais vivre pour le mien
nous allons bien nous sommes Sascha
[Musique]